allora io volevo cominciare con gioco
adesso vi faccio una domanda molto
semplice dovete pensarla pensare la
risposta e poi faremo un alzata di mano
la domanda è cosa fai
pensateci un secondo
allora quanti di voi alla domanda cosa
fai
hanno una risposta diretta alzata di
mano
ok
quanti di voi invece hanno alla domanda
cosa fai
ma non lo so non so bene come spiegarlo
se poi lo spiego tanto non si capisce
parliamo del principe r di meghan markle
quanti di voi allora io ho incontrato
tante persone della mia età più grandi
più piccole e si dividevano nettamente
in queste due categorie cioè chi ha la
domanda cosa fai a la risposta diretta
faccio il programmatore faccio il
magazziniere ciechi alla domanda cosa
fai non ha una risposta in particolar
modo conosco una persona che per 35 anni
alla domanda cosa fai
aveva una risposta chiara e netta faccio
il disegnatore tecnico per un'azienda
che produce frigoriferi quale persona e
mio papà
conosco un'altra persona che per 84 mesi
e il conto continua alla domanda cosa
fai
la risposta non c'era quella persona
sono io
allora mi è capitato in particolar modo
e adesso capiamo la domanda cosa fai non
solo tante volte non avevo la risposta
ma tante volte mi terrorizzava come il
buio il terrorizza i bambini perché
quando me l'ha chiedevano vi cito un
episodio cosa fai
faccio la social media strategist
cazzeggi su facebook
cosa fai faccio la copywriter a voi
diritti copyright non me lo darò mai
spiegami un po no veramente scrivo
allora la fine io l'ho risolto in un
modo molto semplice
cosa fai lavoro due anni fa ho fatto una
piccola grande scoperta e tutte le
grandi scoperte sono anche piccole
teniamocele strette e sono qui per
condividerle la due anni fa ho scoperto
che la domanda cosa fai
non è la domanda la vera domanda è
quante cose sei allora
riavvolgiamo il nastro e ri svolgiamo la
cosa io sono una sorella gemella sono
una sorella gemella che da piccola non
giocava con sua sorella gemella perché
le piaceva raccontarsi le storie con le
barbie e se iniziavamo a giocare in 2
poi le nostre due barbie c'era solo un
ken se lo litigavano e quindi non
funzionava sono una zia che adora
giocare con i nipotini
perché io cinque anni non le ho mai
passati sono una copywriter perché mi
piace scrivere sono ed è una cosa che ho
scoperto e riscoperto poco fa sono una
secchiona sono sempre stata una
secchiona
adoro scoprire cose di cui non avevo la
minima idea e se vi devo dire il momento
più felice della mia vita è stato quando
ho scoperto che una poesia di pirandello
che si chiama esame non aveva la data
che c'era scritto sul libro ma era prima
perché l'avevo scoperto io c'era in una
lettera che pirandello aveva scritto ai
suoi genitori anni prima quello lì me lo
sono segnato un momento felice della
vita sono una persona che ha due grandi
desideri
il primo diventare un genio come dante
il secondo cambiare il mondo
per il primo non ci siamo ancora
arrivati però se mi metto di profilo il
physique du role un po c'è e la mia foto
di laurea con la loro sopra lo di moto
per il secondo due anni fa ho incontrato
un progetto che mi ha aiutato davvero a
scoprire a tirare fuori tutte le cose
che sono
questo è un progetto che adesso ve lo
spiego bene e capite perché continua a
rispondere alla domanda cosa fai lavoro
e non dico nient'altro è un progetto che
trasforma le competenze genitoriali in
competenze chiave per il mondo del
lavoro come la capacità di ascoltare la
capacità di essere empatici la capacità
di gestire il tempo la capacità di
gestire le persone e questo ci porta all
ultima cosa
l'ultima almeno fino ad oggi delle cose
che sono che è solo una life based
learning researcher ora capite perché di
quando mi chiedono cosa fai lavoro light
based learning l'apprendimento basato
sulla vita è quello di cui mi sto
occupando adesso è la cosa bella è che
ci dice esattamente questo
quante cose sei è la vera domanda a cui
rispondere
non è cosa fai e la cosa bella è la cosa
bella non solo per me ma per tutti noi è
che non lo dico solo io ma lo dicono se
guardate le ultime ricerche del bel
mondo del lavoro che ci dicono che tra
un vent'anni il 65 per cento di lavori
potranno essere automatizzati che ci
dicono che da 75 a 275 milioni di
persone dovranno ricambiare le
competenze ma che ci dicono soprattutto
che ci sono 10 competenze chiave che
dobbiamo avere tutti e questo è un
report che ha riportato il world
economic forum quindi non mia zia luigia
che abita sotto di me ciao zia grigia e
che ci dice che queste competenze sono
saper ascoltare saper gestire gli altri
saper gestire il tempo saper gestire le
proprie emozioni e se ci pensiamo un
attimo tutte queste competenze non sono
il cosa fa
sono il quante cose sei allora io volevo
condividere questa piccola scoperta e da
domani una piccola cosa da fare da
domani quando vi alzate andate allo
specchio
guardatevi un momento e vidi te quante
cose sei quante cose sono quante cose
voglio essere
non è una domanda facile tante volte la
risposta è no tante volte la risposta
sarà diretta tante volte la risposta non
arriverà ma è la domanda che vale la
pena farsi vale la pena farsi nel lavoro
ma non solo perché quel quante cose sei
è quello che dà e darà sempre di più
senso al cosa fai
grazie
[Applauso]